bachelor fan favorite Tyler Cameron has
a new series and just might be inspired
by one very special leading lady we know
in the workouts now I'm here with my
girl I got to show you this picture of
her stumbling me last night
so Harley's the woman in your bed right
now she is she does no one else did
Harley like Hannah brown she did okay
sometime all right Hannah here's
competition
why did Hannah quarantine with you he
kind of reconnected over some things
that we were both going through and we
were there for each other and it was
never supposed to be that long or a
quarantine it also supposed to be a
weekend where things kind of got a
little crazy like the quarantine and
everything like that Tyler Tyler are you
single right now yes look it's a minute
away but would you be the bachelor I
don't know you know the timing right now
is good for it I there's a lot of things
that have happened in my life lately I
think there's a lot of things I want to
get going in my life as well some
businesses like I want to start my only
my construction company running and all
that that's important to me this whole
world you know having followers and all
this stuff is great off but I want
something that's long lasting and I can
have forever and that's what I hope to
see in a construction company so I my
goal is to get that going and you know
hopefully something I can have with my
kids one day they can have it's been a
whirlwind year for Tyler
almost exactly a year ago we met him and
his dancing on The Bachelorette America
fell in love with him and then watched
him rebound from Hannah brown by dating
supermodel Gigi Hadid which is amazing
person or just keeping it keeping it
friendly well I know that you are not
the father not the father of gigi hadid
x' baby you are incredible at
transitions long Xia thank you
did you know she wanted to do this do
you think she's gonna be a great mom and
have you reached out to her at all she
is she is going to be the most
incredible mom she is one of the
sweetest most caring people I've ever
met so I'm super excited for her right
now Tyler is focused on family he and
his brothers are recovering from the
loss of their mom who tragically passed
away two months ago from a brain
here ism Tyler knows she'd be proud
though as he gets ready to premiere his
new kwibi show Varga texture together we
make some bomb customized dog houses in
each episode
Tyler works with celeb dog parents to
build a customized dream home for their
pup hot dude doing construction and
making houses for adorable dogs
is there a [ __ ] brand show for you my
husband is not nice he can also go in
the doghouse you make some houses for a
couple of my favorite ladies the
housewives riches - any of them flirt
with you or like trying to set you up
with anybody none of that happened they
were just so struck by the dog houses
that you know they kind of just lost you
know they must have forgot about setting
you up with somebody but so we really
took a lot of time to make sure these
things were amazing
these were bigger than my first New York
City apartment the dog house might not
be a punishment anymore and imagine the
rent on those dog houses astronomical
New York prices